en el modelo de borde el átomo de
hidrógeno tenemos un protón en el núcleo
aquí dibujo una carga positiva y un
electrón con carga negativa orbitando al
núcleo más o menos como los planetas
orbitando alrededor del sol y aún cuando
el modelo de bourne no refleja la
realidad no sé es útil para el concepto
del átomo no sirve para calcular por
ejemplo el radio de este círculo que es
lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo así
que vale la pena estudiar este modelo
pero debo advertirles que vamos a
trabajar con mucha física en este vídeo
por lo que si no les gusta mucho la
física los invito a que vean el
siguiente vídeo donde estaremos usando
los resultados obtenidos aquí regresando
al electrón de aquí digamos que el
electrón va en sentido antihorario y la
velocidad del electrón en este punto es
tangente a esta curva y esta será la
dirección del vector velocidad digamos
que el electrón tiene una masa m y este
electrón va a sentir una fuerza va a
sentirse atraído hacia el núcleo las
cargas opuestos se atraen así que este
electrón con carga negativa va a sentir
una fuerza
atrae al centro de este círculo y por
eso será una fuerza centrípeta y en este
caso estamos hablando de la fuerza
eléctrica esta es la fuerza eléctrica
que ocasiona que el electrón se mueva en
un círculo podemos encontrar la fuerza
eléctrica usando la ley de colom y esta
de aquí es la ley de colom a lo que es
igual la fuerza eléctrica cada es una
constante multiplicada por 1 que es una
de las cargas digamos que con 1 es la
carga del protón multiplicada por la
otra carga que es q2 y es la carga del
electrón dividido entre la distancia
entre estas dos cargas al cuadrado vamos
a escribir lo que conocemos en esta ley
de colom k es una constante que veremos
en un momento 1 dijimos que era la carga
en el protón y digamos que la carga del
protón es y así la vamos a llamar por el
momento es una carga elemental q2
dijimos que era la carga del electrón y
el electrón tiene la misma magnitud de
carga que el protón pero es negativa
así que ponemos aquí una negativa
dividido entre la distancia entre ambas
cargas al cuadrado y la fuerza es igual
a la masa por la aceleración esto viene
de la segunda ley de newton y ms era la
masa del electrón y esta será la
aceleración centrípeta ya que estamos
hablando de una fuerza centrípeta y
sabemos que la aceleración centrípeta es
b al cuadrado entre r vamos a sustituir
esto aquí esto es igual a m por d al
cuadrado entre r inmediatamente vemos
que podemos cancelar una de las erres y
ya que nos interesa la magnitud de la
fuerza no nos interesa el número
negativo aquí nos interesa solamente la
magnitud de la fuerza eléctrica así que
podemos simplificar esto un poco y decir
que acá y al cuadrado entre r del lado
izquierdo es igual a m por b al cuadrado
y continuando con la física clásica
usaremos lo que es el momento angular
que es un concepto algo curioso el
momento angular es l mayúscula y una de
sus ecuaciones es r por b donde r es un
vector y p es el momento lineal y el
momento lineal es igual a la masa por la
velocidad así que estamos hablando de el
momento lineal del electrón la masa del
electrón multiplicada por la velocidad
del electrón vamos a sustituir esto en
el momento angular y vamos a tomar el
momento angular en el centro de nuestro
círculo de acá el momento angular en el
centro r es un vector vamos a ponerlo
aquí
y es la distancia desde el centro hasta
donde se encuentra nuestro electrón aquí
tenemos el vector r producto cruz está x
significa un producto cruz que
multiplica al momento lineal entonces es
r que multiplica a m volver por el seno
del ángulo que forman ambos vectores así
que pensemos ahora en el otro vector que
tenemos aquí el otro vector es el vector
momento el vector momento tiene la misma
dirección que el vector velocidad esta
es la dirección de la velocidad y
también la dirección del vector momento
lineal
así que el ángulo entre ambos vectores
es obviamente de 90 grados el seno de 90
grados es 1 por lo que podemos decir que
el momento angular es igual a r por m
por b por 1
nils board pensó que este momento
angular debería estar quant izado y lo
que él hizo fue establecer este momento
angular igual a cierto entero como 1 2 o
3 y así sucesivamente así que le ponemos
un entero n por h que es la constante de
planck dividida entre 2 pi esto es lo
que encontró board y uso esto para
despejar la velocidad
vamos a hacerlo vamos a despejar ve de
la ecuación de la derecha
la velocidad es igual a n por h dividido
entre 2 y m por r
ya despejamos y vamos a usar esto en
nuestra otra ecuación que tenemos aquí a
la izquierda vamos a hacerlo nos queda
acá y al cuadrado entre r es igual a m
por todo esto n por h entre 2 p m r todo
elevado al cuadrado hagamos más espacio
y continuemos resolviendo esto
usemos nuestra álgebra tenemos acá
al cuadrado entre r es igual a la masa
por todo eso al cuadrado en el cuadrado
h al cuadrado entre 4 p
al cuadrado m al cuadrado r al cuadrado
podemos cancelar algunas cosas por
ejemplo una de estas se me saca y una de
estas erres viaja ahora en el lado
izquierdo nos queda acá al cuadrado
igual m al cuadrado h al cuadrado entre
4 x pie al cuadrado por m por r la meta
aquí es despejar el radio de este
círculo y para hacerlo podemos
multiplicar ambos lados por 4 por pie al
cuadrado por m por r y nos queda acá al
cuadrado 4 pi al cuadrado m&r igual a n
al cuadrado h al cuadrado
vamos a despejar r&r va a ser igual a en
el cuadrado h al cuadrado dividido
entre cada x al cuadrado por 4 x piel
cuadrado por m
y ahora vamos a tomar todo esto de acá
y vamos a escribir los números que les
corresponden por ejemplo h es la
constante de planck y sabemos que esto
es 6.626 por 10 a la menos 34
esto va a estar al cuadrado
y va está dividido entre todo esto
acá sí ya vieron física sabrán que acá
es una constante y vale 9 por 10 a 9 es
la carga elemental y la magnitud de la
carga elemental de un protón o un
electrón es 1.6 por 10 a la menos 19
coloms esto es al cuadrado por 4 al
cuadrado y recordamos que m es la masa
del electrón y la masa del electrón es
9.11 por 10 a la menos 31 kilogramos y
bueno estos son bastantes cálculos y en
lugar de sacar mi calculadora y
mostrarles cómo se hacen los invito a
que hagan los cálculos ustedes mismos y
verán que como resultado nos darán 5.3
por 10 a la menos 11 y si se dieron el
tiempo de hacer el análisis dimensional
tendrán como unidades metros
así que hagan estos cálculos de ustedes
y verán que obtendrán este número y este
es un número bastante importante vamos a
usarlo en nuestra ecuación de la
izquierda r es igual a n al cuadrado por
5.3 por 10 a la menos 11 metros
vamos a calcular cuál será el radio para
n igual a 1 esto representa el estado
fundamental de un electrón en el
hidrógeno 100 es igual a 1 está r será
r1 igual a 1 al cuadrado por este número
obviamente esto es un cálculo muy
sencillo así que este radio 1 va a ser
igual a este número 5 puntos 3 por 10 a
la menos 11 metros
así que regresemos aquí a nuestro dibujo
para que vean por qué este número es
importante
acabamos de calcular este radio para el
estado fundamental de un electrón en el
átomo de hidrógeno calculamos esta
distancia y la llamamos r 1 la idea de
niels bohr al cuantificar el momento
angular va a limitar a los radios que
podemos tener
vamos a generalizar esta ecuación
r n n es cualquier entero es igual a n
al cuadrado por este radio r 1 en el
cuadrado por r 1 que acabamos de
encontrar y el 5.3 por 10 a la menos 11
metros
r para cualquier entero n es igual a n
al cuadrado por r 1 y esa es una
ecuación muy importante ya que significa
que sólo ciertos radios están permitidos
en este modelo del átomo de hidrógeno
debido a que niels bohr quant hizo el
momento angular así que debemos tener
radios específicos hablaremos de los
otros radios en el siguiente vídeo así
que en este vídeo después de toda esta
física llegamos a esta ecuación y la
usaremos para ver más detalles de los
radios del modelo de voz